Robert De Niro and Robert De Faro and
shoelace love it's episode 46 of IMG
here's a great infographic about New
Year's resolutions for instance 88% of
them fail but you see these images of
cats they are cat scans for something
sweet check outs candy bars a tumblr
with high resolution cross-sectional
scans of candy less appetizing is this
rare and very real
albino shark Cyclops Kyle Beane took
these soft gorilla photographs a jello
Hand Grenade a feather knife brass
knuckles toast and a delicious melting
time bomb almost as delicious as
dressing your baby as a Thanksgiving
turkey a homeless person or a creeper
the splash of water caused by a droplet
impacting a pool is called a Worthington
jet now the jet can break into droplets
and this droplet refracting a world map
behind it creates a globe that blows my
mind
image released the 11 most loaded images
on their site in 2011 the most viewed
gif of course was the cafeteria ninja
the hands counted down their sights
top 10 most appreciated projects for
instance honest logos for YouTube
Facebook and more I also love these
brand verse asians logos made out of
logos from competing products okay now
these works use negative space to make
two pictures simultaneously this one
reminds me of a psychology study from
the late 1800's showing how culture
influences perception Western viewers
are familiar with box-like
architecture and corners and so they
report that this image is a family
sitting indoors with the window looking
outside but participants from East
Africa interpreted the family to be
sitting outside under a tree while this
woman balances a box on her head okay
here's a field of squares now follow the
moving dot and the middle squares will
appear to rise and fall
and you know what how about some finger
drums
you
[Music]
here's a human Santa peed and here's
something neat Jodi Benson she did the
voice for Ariel in the Little Mermaid
and she's the same person who does the
voice for Barbie in Toy Story now this
image of the world shows global cloud
cover average over the month of October
2009 but clouds are more fun when
they're in weird shapes or positions
speaking of clouds let's talk about
William Rankine a Marine Corps pilot who
ejected from his failing aircraft and
sky douve right through the middle of a
thunderstorm fluctuating pressure in the
storm set off his automatic parachute
early and he was tossed around inside
the thunder clouds more than 10,000 feet
above the ground
for more than 40 minutes before finally
landing in a tree but reddit alerted me
to scarier weather the weather over the
USA on December 27th a t-rex about to
eat Iowa now finally these books have
been carved into landscapes by guy
Laramie on facebook.com slash Vsauce
gaming you can submit your own images
dogs questions and generally Vsauce it
all up together for instance jonathan
submitted these carved books that
together make a tree which is what they
started out as anyways and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]